en nueva delhi algunos lugares públicos
son verdaderos oasis en el corazón de la
ciudad lugares de descanso para la gente
que quiere alejarse el ajetreo de la
megalópolis durante algunas horas o
minutos los jardines lobby son uno de
esos lugares sobre todo temprano por la
mañana cuando las temperaturas frescas
se prestan para el ejercicio físico
muchos vienen aquí a diario desde hace
años es un lugar muy hermoso la gente
viene aquí para hacer deporte y cuidar
de su salud pero también por la belleza
de los monumentos antiguos muchos de los
parques de la capital india combinan
espacios verdes con monumentos de
distintas épocas
especialmente en este cuidado y no solo
en la historia a través del arte de la
época
este patrimonio arquitectónico y los
espacios abiertos que los rodean forman
parte de la vida cotidiana de nueva
delhi pero uno de estos lugares más
emblemáticos populares entre los
lugareños y los turistas está ahora
amenazado comparable a los campos
delicioso al sensual park
el central vista en el corazón de la
ciudad está cerrado para realizar
grandes obras el gobierno indio demoler
a muchas estructuras públicas y jardines
para dar paso a oficinas y a un nuevo
parlamento para esta historiadora el
llamado proyecto de desarrollo cambiará
la naturaleza del lugar
lo que llamamos vista central comienza
desde la cancula que se ve nos da lado y
sigue derecho en esta dirección hasta el
arco que se ve allá de la puerta de
india
aún más allá creo que estos cambios van
a alejar a los visitantes normales entre
comillas nuevo la gente que solía venir
aquí sólo para relajarse
este nuevo proyecto también se supone
que romperá con el legado colonial
británico
es un argumento muy problemático porque
si lo piensan estos edificios fueron
construidos bajo un gobierno colonial
pero durante más de 70 años la historia
de la india independiente se ha
construido aquí entonces de qué historia
queremos deshacernos realmente
las obras con un costo de dos mil
millones de euros comenzaron en medio de
la controversia en medio de la segunda
ola de coronavirus devastadora en india
para muchos el proyecto es una medida
autoritaria
los que toman estas decisiones los
espacios y preguntarles a los ciudadanos
que son realmente los puse mi culo
y usted
el proyecto central vista reaviva el
debate sobre los espacios públicos y la
conservación del patrimonio en la
capital en la vieja delhi y su laberinto
de callejones del siglo 17 los
residentes llevan décadas luchando por
ser escuchados por las autoridades
la familia de socma tur ha vivido aquí
durante siete generaciones ha visto como
el barrio se ha degenerado en todas
estas cortinas metálicas por todas
partes
antes había hermosas puertas y patios en
lugar de estos depósitos de dos figuran
todo estas calles están llenas de
historia pero completamente descuidadas
el gobierno de nueva delhi acaba de
reconstruir una de las principales
arterias de vieja de él y para
convertirla en una calle peatonal en
torno al famoso mercado de chandni chowk
si bien es una restauración estética
para socma tour es un cambio superficial
para mí es un despilfarro de dinero
público se trata de un verdadero
desarrollo de viaja del yo o de simples
retoques cosméticos porque si uno sale
de todas las calles y están descuidadas
esta calle peatonal es para los turistas
no para los locales o para mí no es un
desarrollo colectivo en nueva delhi los
monumentos bien conservados no son más
que un puñado de los más de 2.000
vestigios repartidos por toda la ciudad
muchas de estas estructuras en ruinas
parecen casi olvidadas se mezclan con
las viviendas de la capital y los
barrios repletos de gente la ciudad está
ganando terreno y un día podrá engullir
estos monumentos históricos
allí hay kumar lleva años luchando por
proteger este patrimonio amenazado
estos módulos son reliquias históricas
pero siguen siendo analizadas porque no
hay un plan de mantenimiento
conservación renta y grafitis por todas
partes también muy mal estado porque por
un gran problema de insensibilidad
preservar estos monumentos es una ardua
batalla un reto para las próximas
generaciones
él tiene potencial para ser patrimonio
de la humanidad que debemos cuidar esta
historia e incluir nuestro primo en los
proyectos de desarrollo la historia debe
conservarse presentarse en formar parte
de estos desarrollos futuros durante
décadas los partidos políticos han
intentado dejar su huella en la capital
mediante grandes proyectos emblemáticos
en nombre del desarrollo por desgracia
los habitantes y su patrimonio histórico
suelen quedar olvidados en estos
proyectos urbanos